I think the first and most important
question is why
well
um
you know I've been doing this for 21
years and I love it I'm still very
passionate about it and make no mistake
I'm not I'm not moving on from
television I'm just moving on from
daytime they're going to drop a hammer
on you and prosecute you to the full
extent of them do my time in jail jail
ain't nothing
that's what I always do and they never
catch me what does that mean because
people now are wondering you know I've
been working for quite some time to put
together a a prime time
opportunity here and I can't talk about
it yet because I'm about to close all
the details of this but I wanted to
partner with a network so I can do some
things in prime time that really have
significance not just a show but a whole
approach to what's going on in America
right now because Kevin I'm very
concerned I have grave concerns about
what's happening in America right now I
mean aren't you I mean I don't talk to
anybody that isn't right I'm concerned
that the American families under attack
that our values are under attack that
are the very concept of Truth is under
attack and I wanted a bigger audience a
bigger play a bigger platform uh than
daytime can't afford and so I've been
working on that and I'm going to be
revealing that soon and I expect to
return to the air in January of 24 in a
really big way okay and you say January
24th because there is also speculation
out there people are like is he running
for office is he going to do something
like that oh hell no okay that's what I
just want to make sure I'm apolitical
you know I see things that I think are
absolutely crazy on both sides of the
island I'm going to say so and look my
commitment is to helping people do what
they need to in their lives learn what
they need to use in their lives and be
of service to them and that's what I'm
going to focus on I'm not I'm not
getting ready to do a political show
you're not going to confuse me with CNN
or fox or CNBC it's going to be Dr Phil
I think at my highest and best use of
Television dealing with couples dealing
with families but how everything that's
going on is impacting them and seeing
things through their eyes have you
counted how many daytime shows you've
done since you started I really haven't
three thousand nine hundred and forty
but
all right a
3940 shows and we've got more to do this
year and
I I have to say I I feel such a bond and
it may sound corny to say because most
of these people I've never met but I
feel such a bond with the daytime
viewers and I I so hope they're going to
follow me to the next platform and I
believe they will but they've been so
loyal and so good and so true uh I'm
gonna make them proud because today you
know Tom Brady retired I thought you and
Tom Brady retired on the same day and
right and uh we got together talked
about it and said this is a time to do
it so we can follow Beyonce on tour
where'd you get done uh I had a total
knee replacement done uh by Dr Jason
snippy absolute artist I mean the best
of the best and I had it done just a
number of days ago and
I you know I've spent my life in sports
as you have and you know it takes a toll
I think it's worth the price but you
know she along in the tooth some of
these things start breaking down and we
now have the technology to change it so
I have a total knee replacement it got
to where I was just bone on bone and it
got to where it was hard to sometimes
walk on and off the stage because it was
just really grinding and bone on bone so
I replaced it and it's gone fabulously
will you let me get you to the doctor so
you can get checked out
if you so much as attempt to get my moon
more
deal I'll leave it alone you have had
incredibly memorable moments in daytime
moments that have resonated across this
country and around this world
I know it's a hard question to ask but
do you have your favorites for me it's a
category
um rather than a a particular show in
the category are those where
children are caught in a in an adult
trap and they have no voice they have no
ability to get out of it and having had
the chance to give those children a
voice
give them protection I feel good at
night when I go home knowing you know
somebody threw this child a rope and got
them some assistance some protection
some help and those are the things that
you really feel good about how hard will
it be for you to drive off that
Paramount lot because every day you come
in through the same gate you park in
that place you know every guard you go
to the water tower where everybody eats
you know everybody on that lot how hard
will that day be well I've tried not to
think about that but
it when I came out here
I I didn't know how long this was going
to last I mean you know there had been
dozens and dozens of shows that
um had been launched and I was talking
to Oprah just a short time ago and it's
like 21 years can you believe it and
she's like you know really it seems like
it went by that fast but on the other
hand that's been our life I came out
here I had a whole career in life and
everything and so we're we came out here
as fans you know we see people and we've
never even tried to be cool about it
we're just in love with the whole thing
and uh it's been a wonderful wonderful
experience there and
um Paramount has been great and that's a
lot that's been a wonderful community
and everybody there has just been great
so we've
we're gonna miss it I'll put it that way
one other thing um prime time TV shows
that you're developing scripted shows
are you developing more scripted shows
will there be more content like that too
certainly and very soon actually there's
things around the lip of the cup and
really I can't tell you what they are
but they're around the lip of the cup
and we're very proud of so help me Todd
right now we're syndicating Bull and uh
we're working on bringing iteration of
that back to broadcast as well and then
we have a medical show that we're
getting ready to do that's very
different I can't wait to tell you about
all the prime time things that we're
working on just as soon as I can you'll
be my first call you got it
foreign
[Music]